[Music]
in opposing this mask um I'll introduce
myself my name is Eileen Walsh my son
was firefighter Michael Brennan L of
four engine 54 Battalion 9 New York City
he left his senior year of college as a
licensed PL
to go work for the fire department he
received a letter he called me and I
gave him my blessing because he truly
loved it he was on the department 6
years he was 27 years old when the
towers were viciously attacked by Muslim
terrorists and he also my youngest
daughter is here and she probably is not
aware of this because my husband and I
and my ex-husband and his wife
chose not to have the children know when
his remains returned six times I got a
phone call and it was two years ago that
I was able to put a tombstone up I just
had a feeling there was more after the
first time he was identified so I relate
to
Rosaline and Mrs Bowen with the uh with
those envelopes
coming but Michael uh these towers that
were destroyed there was buildings
destroyed around them one of them was
the Burlington Co Factory this is the
very same building that our terrorists
now would like to build an Islamic
Cultural
Center be and our Towers were destroyed
because of the hatred of the American
way of life and now they dare to build a
mosque and a cultural center on this
sacred site this action is insulting to
me as a parent of one of the victims and
it insults the majority of Americans
it's consentable to erect a mosque on a
ground zero site it reveals a lack of
compassion and respect on the part of
Muslims and non-muslim supporters
towards the victims their families their
friends their neighbors and their
communities supporters would have you
believe this is about religion it is not
since 9/11 many mosques have been built
at least 30% of the mosque in America
have been built since 9/11 without
objection or
incident this is about location location
location as as culture and politics and
spirituality are integrated in the
Islamic teachings many Muslims would
view this Islamic cultural center and
mosque as a victory Tower since it would
stand on sacred ground of groundzero and
destroyed by their Muslim Brothers at
this time I would like to ask my
moderate Muslims for their support to
support our pleas of opposing this
particular location and at the same time
I would like to ask those that are here
to reach out to your local politicians
whether you're from New York or around
the country to ask them to stand beside
us I
compliment oh Dana Hollin who was here
I'm from Queens and I spoke with my
local councilman behind the scenes he
opposes this not one would stand up
beside us so Dana hollerin I
congratulate him for being here with us
and it's a wonderful thing so I would
ask moderate Muslims and supporters to
try to compromise and come to another
site in Manhattan there are many
locations that they can choose they want
this because it stands for victory over
America thank you
I'd like you to hear from Rosal leonetti
she's a she's a a a warrior she's spok
at my rallies uh she's smart girl
politics uh she's uh I can't thank her
enough for the work that she's done and
I'm sorry that we ran so
long I have to get back to the booth
Duty